- I talk about playlists a lot
because it's full of randomness.
I like his playlist.
Like I, the first time we hung out,
I know I've said this story before,
but I was so shocked!
I was like, is this Duran Duran?
(laughing)
I was like, what?
Like you have the most random playlist.
So, you're totally country, obviously,
but you have like a pretty broad--
- I listen to everything, yeah.
- Yeah, you have really broad playlist.
So, to find out why Blake loves
some of those random songs,
we come up with a little game
because I know he loves games.
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
Called, I just bring my friends here
and make them do stuff
they don't wanna do.
It's called Celebrity Playlist Shuffle!
(electric guitar music)
(audience applauding)
Alright, so here's how it works, okay?
I hit this button, you know we--
- Wait a minute, wait, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
wait a minute.
Is this the same piece of crap button
that you had last time?
- Dude, it's, yes, yes!
It is a fresh, do you
wanna offer some money,
you wanna be a sponsor for this season?
- No, I'm just sayin'.
(audience laughing)
- This the first season.
- We're on television,
right, this is a big show?
Didn't you get renewed for another season?
- We did, but we don't have the money yet.
(audience applauding)
We didn't have the money yet.
- Wait a minute, where's the elf?
I brought you something.
- You brought me a gift?
- Yes.
- That's kind.
- Okay, what is it?
- Yes, elf, can you please bring it.
(laughing)
'Cause that is embarrassing.
- I know.
- How come the elf don't
come when I say it?
Oh, here is is, right here.
(audience cheering)
- Oh!
Oh my God, it has drink in it.
Oh my God.
- This is the new and
improved Kelly Clarkson
(laughing)
stupid game podium.
- Stupid game.
(audience laughing)
Wait, does it light up?
Oh!
- What ever game that you
make your friends play.
- It lights up!
- As long as you have to be
uncomfortable on this show,
playing your weird games.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Now you actually have
like a nice podium.
And it's got, look here.
- Rear view mirrors.
- Rear view mirrors,
'cause somebody like--
- [Kelly] Yeah, somebody coming at me.
- Like you do that deal where, you know,
like a soldiers gonna
surprise a family member
but it didn't work, 'cause the kids like,
"Oh my God, there's dad!"
(laughing)
It's not gonna work now.
- [Kelly] It's not gonna work.
- [Blake] Got this, got the cup holders.
- [Kelly] I like that, it's
a little like beer-pong,
but it's button-pong.
- And my favorite, because
everytime you use this,
I want people to know.
(audience laughing)
Blake is awesome.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I'm actually
gonna keep that on there.
- [Blake] Blake is awesome.
(laughing)
- That's amazing.